alright getting to this one kind of late
yeah later than was yesterday though
yeah that's true we saw a pretty good
documentary last night on what was that
shut was like Netflix right yeah it's
bad LSD called have a good trip yeah
adventures in psychedelics yeah it's
pretty good you had all these
celebrities and stuff and like you know
some I guess some scientist it wasn't
wayside is it Deepak Chopra pseudo
pseudo intellectual is what you're
talking about there LSD trips over the
years and this funny they had some old
army propaganda films about the danger
the dangers of it you could take it just
go crazy one time doesn't work that way
well I know it's like what this [ __ ]
old drug films like always crack me up
man it's just like you know that you
know the very famous one [ __ ] Reaper
madness yeah which they did on MST Ron
RiffTrax rather and it's just like that
it's like they clearly don't know anyone
that smokes pot because nobody in reefer
madness behaves in any way the way
people on pot behave they told him to
behave like that they're just like scare
tactics yeah don't try this kids yeah
look even though I have to say that like
some of the [ __ ] they were doing the
movie I'm like well I don't think that
would encourage anybody away from it
because they look like they're having a
good time it was funny laughs it's funny
cuz like a lot of the anti weed ones you
know they're talking about how bad weed
was and the guys narrating it and the
people that are saying this are [ __ ]
pound and a half a [ __ ] fifth of
vodka day yeah we have to fit the
whiskey way worse than this from
somebody that likes to drink and I don't
particularly like pot because yeah it
never I I've only done it a few times
but it never cuz you know how some
people are like they like Fox that kind
of mellows a mountain [ __ ] I have like
the exact opposite reaction it just
makes me super super paranoid and
self-conscious and I kind of hate it it
was a generational thing you know I mean
yeah old people like my grandparents age
were afraid to anything they didn't know
what it was yeah you know I mean oh
that's gotta be [ __ ] really bad you
all are hopped up on the goofballs yeah
Mexicans do that it's gotta be bad
like we don't know that like how people
don't realize it like out west in the
california/nevada that area you not I
mean
but can we drew their going back to the
1800s well yeah and Mexicans would bring
it and sell it
you know knit sell to little you know
called wacky tabacky had all kinds of
[ __ ] weird old-fashioned names for it
camp you know you know mary-jane
marijuana yeah and you know Mexicans
would sell it and Cowboys would buy it
and they smoked it they didn't have a
problem with it it wasn't until much
later that yeah I mean that they tried
to ban it and I think it's because they
couldn't tax it probably because
although it finally were getting around
the like [ __ ] legalizing the [ __ ] now
it's like for Christ's sake it was I
think it I think it had more to do the
fact that you know local governments
couldn't tax it because it wasn't really
an American product and the way it was
being imported in was like on people's
backs so it was hard to do legal
importation and gets they can get their
cut of the [ __ ] you know I mean cut
of the profits but alcohol was being
produced in the United States and it
could tax that it was in the system yeah
so maybe so it might have been a case
where cuz you know how all the
demonization that happened around say
absence right that was mostly the
propaganda behind that and so making
hallucinate and all this other kind of
years also largely untrue that was
usually though the wine manufacturers
that were putting that forward they were
trying to like scare people away from
drinking absinthe because it was cutting
into their market share yeah and guess
what is bet guess of how it guess by
what mechanism they did this fake news
they did it with fake news they hired
newspaper articles to write [ __ ]
scary [ __ ] scary stories about absinthe
to get Pete to keep people away from
buying absinthe lardo to buy [ __ ]
sherry and wine yeah stuff and which is
so stupid because guess where the
absinthe drinking came from the French
army yeah the French army was issuing it
to their own troops as a water
purification yeah they knew was safe
yeah yeah and the reason why people were
drinking is because veterans would come
back and they would liked the taste a
taste for it sure
when they were in service they would
just pour it into a canteen to kill all
the all the bacteria and drink it but
they also found this [ __ ] you know it's
good straight to but I think they mostly
mixed it yeah back in the day think they
had mixed it with things I can see why
nowadays when people drink it even
though the the formula isn't really the
same as it was like the kind of the
classic absinthe back you today but
nowadays people usually water down or
put sugar in it and I can see why they
do that because it is very very very
bitter like even ones that you can buy I
don't know if you can get it anymore but
like the company I used to work for had
one called lucid that they distributed
and it's good but I can't really get
down more than a more than a glass of it
because it's fair I don't like that that
flavor that licorice II yeah you have to
really kind of be into that flavor which
is funny because they they assumed
nobody knew in modern times what
absinthe tasted like they assumed it was
kind of a nice flavored or black
licorice flavored but I saw a
documentary on it I guess it's about ten
years and out they found a bottle of the
original [ __ ] and he auctioned it off
and they had to the largest absence
makers [ __ ] in a bidding war behind
that sealed bottle because they wanted
to know what it tasted like and one side
one and then they take it back to their
laboratory and had all these tasters and
everything they're getting ready to
taste this [ __ ] and they opened it up
and they were just like oh yeah okay
very different and what we thought yeah
it's just kind of buttery see if it was
buttery I that sounds that sounds better
and you know they said it basically
shattered all their expectations of what
they thought absence was supposed to
taste like they thought it's supposed to
taste like strong and aromatic and and
you know kind of like I nice with a
bunch of herbs herbs and [ __ ] and that
no it was kind of like a buttery mellow
flavor and which that sounds delightful
yeah I would I would drink absinthe all
the time if that was how it tasted yeah
and they only kind of knew the only kind
of knew some of the ingredients you know
like I said well wormwood
in it but evidently that was kind of
open to debate because the the the
recipes that they had written down were
not necessarily from like first-hand
accounts of what was in it it was kind
of like old accounts of what they
thought was in it yeah but when they
opened it it just kind of had a buttery
smooth kind of flavor it wasn't too
it wasn't too [ __ ] when he cut didn't
taste like wacom it didn't didn't taste
like herbs yeah what didn't taste
terrible interesting yeah I have a I
have a couple of books that kind of go
into like the history of absinthe I
should reread them cuz they were
actually really fascinating the guy that
was doing the tasting for that company
was like I don't know about that so it's
like god damn it we did manufacturing
this stuff that tastes like licorice all
this yeah evidently he wasn't too
impressed with what it really did taste
like he didn't think maybe it was like
nothing's fashion there's nothing
special he didn't think he didn't think
it was anything kind of market I mean
one thing about the modern iteration of
absinthe is that it has a very
distinctive flavor whether you like it
or not yeah what came out of that bottle
didn't really have a distinctive flavor
II didn't think the sound too impressed
with it of course well yeah Center
Santee they like the bottle was like
really really it was really old though
that might not be what it tasted like
right out maybe gate he thought he knew
what was in it from what I remember and
I haven't seen it I haven't seen that
documentary but from what I remember and
this is like 10 years ago he was pretty
sure he knew what it was and he is like
one of these dudes I had like a his
tongue was worth millions of dollars he
was kind of like a super taster he could
tell you exactly what it was and what
you know well you know he could
replicate something based just on taste
yeah interesting well know the way they
could probably do like chemical analysis
on it is whatever gonna do that - yeah
we're gonna do that - but evidently he
was really good kinda you knows perfume
smells I could smell perfume it tell you
exactly what what they have to do that
he was like that but is but it was taste
and he thought he knew it was but he
wouldn't say on camera because he didn't
want other people making it yeah
I think they paid millions of dollars
that damn bottle yeah so they're like we
don't want to get everybody in the world
for cranek but yeah so the this
documentary was like actually really
really good it helped that they had all
the people it's basically just kind of
like different it's mostly comedians and
then those actors and stuff sting was on
there yeah Anthony Bourdain was on there
and [ __ ] like that and they were
basically just like talking about their
experiences with LSD like whether they
had good trips or bad trips like some
crazy [ __ ] and then there was like a
really funny like they did like a modern
reenactment of like one of the old like
scare videos that was supposed to be set
in the 80s I guess and it was just like
that was pretty [ __ ] hilarious like
with a bunch of comedians and stuff but
some of the [ __ ] store I mean I was
dying like some of the [ __ ] story
Rosie Perez Astoria oh good one she got
dosed yeah she didn't do it on purpose
she was in says club in New York you
know I don't know if you know who she is
she's a soul short cute Puerto Rican
chick with big boobs and she was just in
birds and play wasn't she yeah and she
was and she got dosed and was on her
back on the dam she thought the wooden
floor was water and she splashed and she
didn't realize it but her top was off
everybody was marveling and she's
because mom my boobs look really good
he's got a funny
and then she said well she said it was
really funny because because the I guess
the bartender had dosed her yeah like at
this club and he thought she knew yeah
because he kept saying are you sure he
walked or this punch like fruit punch um
you know she's like yeah it's really
good but so she didn't realize that she
was like tripping on acid and so she's
yeah she's like swimming through the
dance floor she gets home and she's like
she lays down in the bed she thought
like she thought that her body had like
become the mattress yeah she's like so
I'm getting up to go to the bathroom I'm
like going down the hall like that
because she thought that she was an
actress I've never had it that bad like
that's some good [ __ ] that's like yeah
that's what I mean like it just seemed
like most of the people um you know some
of the people that have done it a lot
you know like sting or Anthony Bourdain
or somebody like that that had done a
bunch of times they did say that they
had had bad things happen but sting
actually said whenever I had a bad trip
he's like I you know it was scary at the
time but then later on I thought well I
guess I needed to see that or I need him
that to go on because he had to have his
ego taken down or not yeah which I guess
I was like well that's kind of a good
way of looking at it is naughty [ __ ]
he is yes but he was like he was
entertaining and say everybody was
entertaining on this like everybody had
really good stories and none of them are
like horrifying or anything like that
other than [ __ ] Anthony Bourdain and
that one was women like the girl that
they thought was that they thought died
or whatever this is kind of horrifying
yeah yeah cool celebrity getting high
stories yeah they were very very funny
it's a I don't know it's like I always
like to watch stuff about people's LSD
experiences yeah cuz you know III never
found of it you know if I've only done
it once but I I had a very positive
experience and I and I could see how
because they had like a doctor on there
who s he's doing like some studies um
you know I guess they've a few years ago
they started like I'm studying it to you
know treat some types of mental
illnesses and stuff like that and I said
I could totally see how it in certain
people and with certain ailments it
could relieve stress and anxiety and
stuff like that because you know one of
the things that it does maybe it doesn't
do this to everybody but one of the
things that it does is it kind of makes
you feel like everything's gonna be okay
man you know what I mean like it gives
you like perspective on so is it's also
all that introspection though you can
you know you can weed out your own
problems and throw out a lot of [ __ ]
yeah a lot of things can be resolved in
the unconscious and the subconscious by
taking that as long as you're around the
right people you know you got to be
around friends or you have to [ __ ]
know what you're doing with it it's not
for everybody then yeah but you know
under under supervision is very
effective
you know evidently and I could see why
because I've known actually guys who
were a dick
to certain things you could take acid
and when they come off acid they're no
longer addicted to whatever it was yeah
I mean if I think if you approach it and
they did kind of like some of the people
that had done it like some of the
comedians and stuff they were talking
about it um if you approach it with the
right mindset yeah and you kind of like
see it as a sort of mind altering thing
or you know whatever I do think it does
help you sort out some [ __ ] treating
addiction treating [ __ ] PTSD you know
it's good for certain things Indians
have known all about it problem yeah
yeah I can totally see how it would be
effective for people doing that because
like I said it's you know I I really I
really liked it because it like chilled
me Wade the [ __ ] out and I was like and
and I definitely felt like everything's
alright psychic visions visions of the
future visions of the past visions of
possible futures all kinds of weird [ __ ]
[ __ ] the Mesoamericans you know view
used it forever the model yeah the
Aztecs they knew all about it they knew
all about psychotropics well it was
legal up until what the early sixties I
want to say yeah it was legal until like
to say almost the seventies yeah I think
people some people were abusing it but
they weren't abused and abused
everything doesn't matter yeah people
wrecked cars it's not it's you don't
want to drive on the [ __ ] yeah they had
stories about that I got it there's a
kid as long as you don't think about it
it works out okay I don't want to
[ __ ] think too much about it just I
just let your autonomic nervous system
take over yeah I was laughing it's like
I had the feeling that I could just look
out the window I didn't even have to be
here now we were kids we used to drive
on it did have a problem yeah you just
have to have the right mindset it's like
I said you can't you can't [ __ ] freak
yourself out and I do think too cuz they
kind of went into this and actually you
told me this prior and I'd heard it from
other people it's like well it's
probably a good idea like not to look in
a mirror just because sometimes like
seeing your own reflection will kind of
like weird you out or like
your face well are doing weird [ __ ] or
I've done this several dozen times over
the years you know but you can look in
the mirror just say it's best when
you're experienced some people will look
in the mirror on purpose yeah I think I
said he was having out-of-body
experiences and becoming one with the
earth yeah and he thought it was good
that way too but when you're kind of new
to it you don't want to spare to stare
too much in the mirror because you do
look funny yeah you look funny you know
I mean you don't you might blow your
mind too much yeah I think that's why
they discourage but like fur yeah but
you know I've done it a few times you
understand you understand what what a
hallucination is yeah I don't know
loosening my tripping my balls off and
[ __ ] and I don't believe any of my
hallucinations I know it's a
hallucination well that's what the
coolest things that I found about LSD
was that in a way it's like being drunk
in the sense that it like you know like
a good drunk whereas you're like kind of
chilled out you're not anxious about
anything but you're totally lucid at the
same time because we're yeah cuz
sometimes when you get drunk like
sometimes you'll forget stuff like oh
man I don't remember everything that I
did last night and that happens you know
even when you don't drink all that much
but LSD I remember like you see weird
[ __ ] but you know that it's not real
yeah you know what I mean I mean at
least I did I mean you know I'm sitting
there looking at the laptop going
looking at old David Bowie videos and
I'm having like a psychic experience you
know David Bowie talking to me yeah
sending me messages and [ __ ] I'm
understanding Bowie I got a personal
relationship with Bowie through the
[ __ ] screen but I know I'm tripping
yeah I've just I just roll with it
anyway I don't fight anything I just
roll with it like that's what kind of
what you have to do just yeah and I mean
I I remember I remember thinking
thinking that I was a werewolf not
really thinking that I was aware when
you were like one but like aware yeah
and wanting to go out and don't you go
outside he was trying to get keep me
from going out she was gonna go [ __ ]
dig around out like a good idea at the
time yet and I've cut and it's funny
because I was trying to I was crying
trying to
message my friend over messenger because
she was like had been asking me about it
and so I was like trying to tell her
like in the moment like what it was like
like what I was experiencing and my
laptop just kept going like I could and
like my fingers looked really long so I
was having a hard time doing so after a
while I decided caller that's all just
like visual distortion it's like visual
distortion get it wouldn't be still long
enough for me that's not what that's
really not what it's about it's really
you want to go like you want to go
introspective with it and go inward
that's you know put it on blindfolds and
stuff like that doing it tonight and
laying down that's you start going in
and having visions and you know seeing
futures and it's weird you know but it's
just it's it's the same thing your mind
does when you're dreaming it's just that
you're awake and it's a lot more intense
and you can control it when you get it
certain my experience yeah you like
being able to control your dreams which
I've had that happened a couple times
I'm in the dream I know I'm dreaming and
then I caused the dream to become
something I wanted to be listen dreaming
yeah but then it after a while though
you you wear it out so like when you
tried to control it too much you wake up
yeah well now let's tease like that but
you don't wake up yeah yeah which is
good do you know how to use it
Indy's now to use it man spirit walking
going into the spirit world it's true
yeah well you know I like I said I can
see why it's used gunstar it yeah I've
taken it you know on occasions and done
stuff and realizations have you know
come over me like oh that person
actually isn't my friend oh this person
did this you know I mean it kind of like
because the unconscious mind starts
sending you them signals yeah and starts
connecting dots that you and your waking
self didn't connect yeah you know like
you said in some ways the way sometimes
when you're dreaming like sometimes I
wake up and you'll be like oh you
figured out that for you somehow like
while your brain was sleeping same type
of thing except here and a lot of this
badass music people our way into comes
from that yeah
comes from LSD they're taking it yeah
you know the police and [ __ ] sting as
LSD doing that [ __ ] he went the whole
[ __ ] nine yards man he went down to
[ __ ] he climbed the mountain they got
blood poured on his head
yeah at all that [ __ ] the cure yeah
that's all
d-type music the Beatles
[ __ ] Rolling Stones well yeah you can
innovate art real well on it if you're
if you're a you know if you're an
artistic person you don't use artistic
talent you're not gonna be that good
trained musician and you know they
already have musical talent you give
them that and they'll [ __ ] come up
with a wild [ __ ] yeah true that and I
you know and I guess people that are
into into movies that directors and
writers can do it to they come up with
Mandy that's an acid trip that movie was
an acid trip it seriously it was like a
bad trip yeah like a bad trip yeah yeah
so oh the only other thing I wanted to
mention was because I just now read an
article about this apparently this
happened in Tennessee and I guess it was
like a vacation cabin or something and
this woman or these two women were
staying there and evidently these black
bears between five and eleven of them
broke into the house like a little
burglars like they the doors were locked
but they somehow got in I don't know if
they could pick the locks or what these
are like the Bears are taking over you
guys and they came in the house kind of
trashed it not like trashed at trash
that they left all the furniture okay
but they like knocked over a bunch of
stuff and scratch the walls and
everything and then they stole like just
tons and tons of candy they stole like
five pounds of Reese's peanut butter
cups um like a whole bunch of like gummy
bears or gummy worms or something they
took some beer like they just took bags
and bags and bags of candy and like
[ __ ] took off with the [ __ ] isn't
that [ __ ] isn't that [ __ ] crazy
bears dude [ __ ] bears like breaking
in your house and taking all your candy
well they got they got their paws are
kind of like hands they got that pretty
good dexterity and then how to open
things you know they'll open doors I
mean Jenny remembers you know we saw one
I stopped one from getting in somebody's
garage cuz they can get he was heading
for the fridge fridge to open a fridge
economic fridge they can open a car door
yeah
as well they know about car doors so
yeah that's unlock to be sitting there
trying to open it which now I kind of
wonder it's like cuz sometimes cuz we
have black bears around here it's like
what if we left if we left one of the
doors open or the sliding glass door or
something like that they could probably
open that and just walk we're in these
walls right yeah yeah a bear what also
has the intelligence to know that some
doors might slide open yeah they're
totally not dumb unless now that you
want to do that I need to start locking
make sure the clock burn about that
because this lady said the cabin door
was locked and it was like five bears I
got him on video man they'll come into a
house through an open window and go
right up to the refrigerator just open
it and just open it they know and
they'll be in there in the middle of the
damn kitchen sit down
tubs and ice cream
and people running and yell out of and
they're just like hey what's up what's
up yeah food just help them facilitate
they won't leave you want some of this
they're trying to be friendly I'm not
even they're not even you know being
mean they're being friendly a food it's
great
well they just figure there's food in
there so everybody for everybody
communal food yeah look what I found
that's really good that's the facial
expressions you can find that [ __ ] on
YouTube the facial expressions and body
language is just look what I found yeah
did you know this was here lots of it
I'll share it with you
yeah they don't know any better no well
yeah that children doesn't I mean it
just kind of cracks me up that it cracks
me up that these five bears a little a
little bear gang and they just came in
today they didn't take any like food
food all they took was candy and beer no
soda
cuz it's mouse yeah cuz it's nice it's
oh they probably know about getting
drunk Nick well they'd probably know
that there's sweet stuff in those
cancers yeah now I do know that I guess
they can open it yeah I would imagine I
do know that particularly apes like
chimpanzees and stuff like that they
will they will drink alcohol at the AVA
tomb and actually some that have been
raised with humans like nim chimpsky and
those like chimpanzees and stuff they
are absolutely capable of going in
frig and getting a beer and opening it
and sitting in front of the TV and
drinking a beer yeah saw a video guy
down in Africa's South down South Africa
white dude and he had a chimpanzee an
old chimpanzee lived up in a tree and he
didn't know where it came from or
anything it's just an old chimpanzee and
he's at night with set afire and
chimpanzee come out the tree he'd give
the chimpanzee a beer and they'd sit
there and drink beer together get [ __ ]
up on anything and then when it was when
the beer was done he'd hand a chimp a
blanket and the plan he'd take up the
top tree and sleep in the blanket and he
lived in that tree next to the guy's
house it was just a an old chimp that
showed up an old male chimp
he's weird huh guess you got Sydnee he'd
sit in a folding chair and everything
just sit there and look at the fire
drink just like he was a man just like a
person yep and he could he could take
the top off the off the bottle of beer
and everything like it was I think it
was Corona he was drinking take the top
off and a do sit next to him drinking
they're both staring into fire together
like like it's just chill like I'm
commuting animal kingdom man yeah like I
said I was reading something about you
know one of the famous chimpanzees that
had been you know mostly raised around
people and they said that he would that
he would just come in the house even if
you lock the house up he would just come
in the house in the middle of the night
he would just truck on in there open the
fridge get some beer out he'd turn on
the TV and he'd sit on the couch and
watch TV like drinking beer just like a
little person yeah well that's all I got
I got you got anything else Jenny I
don't think so that's probably all we
got to talk about today so anyway we'll
talk to him tomorrow yeah have a good
rest E or Wednesday like and subscribe
yeah do like you always do and we'll
talk to you guys again tomorrow